ish
look where the leather meets the base of
the shoe one puddle and it's funky foot
for sure let's hope there's no rain or
mud pits or anything
well what good are his eyelids if they
don't close all the way
we know he can blink all the way so why
go halfway
have you ever tried to blink halfway do
it now it's really
hard not to mention a horrible way to
moisten the eyes mando just pushes the
porter stroller and it shoots backward
quicker than it had previously moved
before coming to a complete stop
and yeah yeah we see him push doohickeys
on his arm later to get it to move but
he's not doing that currently
it appears to be running on plot
convenience god that
child is so cute good thing disney was
prepared for the merch demands so that
fans didn't have to buy adorably crafted
fan art from independent artists who
were filling a void
that would have led to so much red tape
and countless cease and desist orders
and worst of all it would disappoint
artists and fans around the world
glad that didn't happen
[Music]
oh come on show how are we supposed to
believe any of this is real when
faux yota doesn't have a chunk of enemy
mine lizard running down his face
expecting a child to stay put i can't
believe mando missed the opportunity to
kill two jaws with one disintegration
stone
that's where the saying comes from what
sort of bullets will evaporate an entire
being with their weapons and clothing
but
leave the cloak behind for dramatic
effect i'm asking for a friend
i mean sure this seems like a really
great time to test the range and speed
of your wrist controller for the child
pod
i've personally never been in a
situation where i needed to shimmy up a
metal fortress to dismantle a mobile
scavenger society but if i needed to do
so i'd opt for the slanty side
rather than the sheer climb i mean why
not use the zippy wrench lasso back here
or hell climb up the back where there
are all sorts of things to grab onto
i'm just saying there appears to be a
better way to get to the top of the
though fortress
today i learned that jawas hall spare
parts to the roof so they're within easy
reach for moments such as this
it's probably in a book or a blog that i
don't have time to read man i haven't
seen this much
jawa murdering in a movie since
spaceballs 2 the search for more money
just want to point out that our supposed
badass mandalorian one of the toughest
people in the star wars universe was
just outsmarted and defeated by
jawaz
damn it i really can't get away from how
adorable this
creature is remove a senior cute little
bastard walking
walking walking excitement also i've
watched this episode twice now and i can
confidently say it should be titled
more walking because it's 26 fighting 10
mud 4
talking 2 ship repair 57
walking and 1 eating frogs i don't know
who told them this was a great ratio for
an episode of star wars
but they were wrong this is what was
causing all the fuss
i think it's a child you might think
that mando but you know what happens
when you assume
you make an ass out of you and not baby
yoda or something like that
the jawas steal they don't destroy
that is a super odd distinction and
really hard to prove
in stripping down machinery they could
in fact destroy it no
hey spit that out a visual aid of how
the muppets were treated on disney plus
makes its way into this episode
also kids did you know some people mow
their lawns at night it looks just like
this minus the rain i've had two
neighbors do this over the years and it
baffles me to no end
i could maybe give a pass to one of them
because his lawnmower had headlamps but
the other guy was pushing his push mower
with one hand and using his smartphone
flashlight with the other
anyway nighttime mowing know when you
can see daryl
that's wookiest mando and the child are
given prime seats at the helm
this man would be highly untrustworthy
so why place him in a position of power
within the ship
i find it hard to believe manda would be
anywhere other than the cargo hold or
locked in the tiny jawa bathroom
behold the gaping sphincter i mean
don't behold that much if you stare at
too long you'll question whether or not
to penetrate
at this point i'm not sure why you'd
choose any other ammunition but the
disintegration bullets he's about to
face off against a hairy berserker rhino
from hell
start with the pow fizzle bullets and
then the pew pew gun
how is leaving green machine outside the
cave protecting it why wouldn't he leave
it with nick nolte hell the jaws seem a
safer bet than just leaving it out in
the open like this when there's several
people trying to kill it
some people find this moment terrifying
because of the rib bones but i'm
disgusted by this piss pond
i mean it's either cave mud or monster
piss and honestly
both options are really disturbing to me
oh now you get out your poof poof gun
also we have now arrived at the portion
of the show where the mandalorian kills
a mother to trade her egg for ship parts
you know rather than hunt the jawas in a
smart way until he finds a way to kill
them all
retrieve his gear plus the jawa horde
and then head back home
this great warrior watches the massive
horned beast approach and rather than
roll away
he hangs out and opts for a blowtorch
arm and he does it again a minute later
will he ever learn not using the perfect
opportunity to strike cliche
followed directly by the single strike
insta-kill cliche
also i'm not saying one stab from that
small blade couldn't kill it but i
am saying one stab from that small blade
couldn't kill it once when i was a kid i
slept over my great aunt's house and she
had brown sticky shag carpeting that
smelled like a cough syrup foot bath
i know this because i was designated to
sleep on the floor
anyway i had a flashlight and when
everyone went to bed i was looking
around and the light shone under the
couch which led me to discover that the
carpet was
actually teal meaning the floor was so
disgusting that it turned brown
and i was essentially sleeping on 50
years of dead skin cells and life spills
all unwashed from a carpet that looks a
lot like this
that carpet even with a hairy outside
coating that still looks tastier than a
cadbury egg
this is gonna take days to fix that's
what i thought i mean
look at this thing earlier it was right
up but nope with a little can-do
attitude these two managed to get it
ready for
in-space flight overnight also when did
mando heal after his fight
his ribs are barely in his body after
this and this and this
or this followed directly by this and a
little side smack like this
but now hours later he's lifting ship
parts back into place like he's not even
sore
nah man this is a super grandiose ending
to an episode where not a
thing of any interest happened and yeah
yeah the little green thing not named
yoda used the force but we've seen star
wars
we know it can do this so who gives a sh
trying to wake a sleeping baby
don't [ __ ] with the babysitter if you've
ever wanted to know what it's like to
probe into the back end of cinema sins
and learn our deepest darkest secrets
behind the sins podcast is just what you
need
each week writers aaron that's me today
that's me and jonathan yep discuss what
it takes to create the content that you
enjoy on youtube
hopefully enjoy they probably do i mean
even if they don't we talk about it
that's true i guess i'll just wrap this
up real quick and let you know that you
can listen to behind the scenes here on
youtube
or search for the show on your favorite
podcast player yep
[Music]
[Applause]
hello mrs pig hello mrs sheep can peppa
talk to susie please
i would like to rage
why can't i kill you
now think of the happiest things
it's the same as having wings have fun
storming the castle